kann ich dich was fragen warum machst du
so lange für eine antwort gebraucht ich
wollte einfach nicht allein seien nicht
heute kämpfen aber zog es ist ein film
den man sofort in verbindung mit anderen
firmen die auch so eine doppelung im
namen bonnie and clyde sammeln ließ das
ist auch bis zu einem bestimmten punkt
ist das auch richtig da ist auch in
diesem film eben darum geht es ein paar
in diesem fall eben grün ins träumen so
nennt sie der titel obwohl im film gar
keinen namen haben diese beiden ein
junger mann an junge frau kommen in eine
polizeikontrolle es gibt ein
handgemenges und angenehm und der am
ende ist der polizist und das ganze ist
auf video aufgenommen worden ist also
sofort klar wer das und sie sind auf der
flucht
und auch die musik ist noch frei da
kommen wo sie dann einen helikopter
kleinflugzeug möglicherweise finden um
nach chur es zu schaffen
das ist jetzt das ist die bewegung die
dieser film macht und was er aber anders
macht als bonnie und clyde und sahne und
lewis ist dass er seine spannung nicht
daraus bezieht dass wir parallel sehen
die fliehenden die flüchtenden und die
verfolger sondern wir sehen wirklich nur
die beiden
wir müssen los sofort dass dieses paar
in einer durch das video das eben
virales im netz an einerseits in die
polizei auf den hals hetzt andererseits
aber sie auch eben bekannt machen in
ihrer eigenen community und überall im
land und die sind eigentlich schon
überall wo sie hinkommen sind sie
eigentlich schon eine legende sie werden
überall erkannt und gefeiert es ist eine
eine britische schauspielerin die eine
unglaubliche präsenz sowie daniel und
diese beiden sind ein paar dass man dem
man wirklich alles wünschen sie mit haut
und haaren und lust und angst und körper
und verstand mit allem dabei sind diese
zeit zu genießen das leben und natürlich
auch zu entkommen
ein vor dort mir gefallen
möchtest du hast das und traurigen
gesichtsausdruck ich hatte mitleid
das tolle an diesem film ist abgesehen
davon dass er eine unglaubliche dynamik
hat die aber immer wieder sehr klug auch
unterschnitten wird mit mit zeiten von
ruhe und auch sehr intelligenten
dialogen muss man dank dass er denn
genau das das dass das augenmerk ebenso
wie auf diese beiden die natürlichen
zentrum stehen dass er das augenmerk
auch auf die menschen richtet denen sie
begegnen und das ist so eine art
underground railroad von heute sozusagen
sollen ist ein ein oder zwei nächte
ja was denn jetzt zwei nächte
es gibt eine ganz erstaunliche szene wo
sie heißen ehepaar unterschlupf finden
die tatsächlich unter ihrem gästebetten
diesen ausschnitt wo man rein kriegen
kann und dann wieder in den boden drauf
liegen und es sieht so aus als wäre da
niemand also ließ ihn vorbereitet das
ist nicht einfach mögen
oder so und dieses weiße paar kam einem
so fremd vor also der blick den die
regisseurin auf die wirft ist so fremd
wie der blick eines weißen regisseurs
einer weißen regisseurin auf ein
schwarzes paar möglicherweise in einem
dominant weise film jetzt der schirm ist
gedreht werden von melanie mathys das
ist eine frau die werden die das ist das
spielfilmdebüt die aber nun sehr
renommierte video musikvideo regisseur
anders und wenn man sich zb ein video
anguckt wie williams formation dass in
den jahren nach dem nach katrina spielt
denkt man ein wann kann endlich den film
dieser frau und hier ist er
bist du verrückt und turbo funktion auf
diesen film trotzdem schnell war
unglaublich bewegt und begeistert auch
das ist so ein film gibt denn man muss
vielleicht daran erinnern dass es in den
90er jahren schon mal eine welle
schwarze film gab filme von spatzen
regisseuren und regisseurinnen gab die
dann aber sofort wieder verebbt
und bei uns gar nicht ist die wenig
davon angekommen mehr aus als bei glied
aber in den schwarzen haushalten wurden
die gespielt und viele der menschen die
hier also regisseurin drehbuchautorin
auch die hier beteiligt war
kennen die und beziehen sich auch ganz
explizit auf sie in ihren aussagen zu
dem film ich kann jetzt sogar nicht
sagen weil ich die teilweise gar nicht
oder zum großen teil überhaupt nicht
kenne kann müssen wir so hinnehmen und
sagen es wird wirklich ein 1 1 1 eine
komplexität von beziehungen erleben es
tätigen auch darstellungs und
präsentationsformen hier einmal
aufgerufen die sich vielleicht beim
ersten sehen gar nicht unbedingt
ausschließen kann schon probiert
recht hast du mich dann bitte für den
rest der strecke
ich kann ihnen sagen die frage ist ja
wenn wir filme von schwarzen regisseurin
sehen was ist eigentlich so anders als
wenn es eine weiße gedreht hätte und sie
müssen sich den film angucken um das
rauszukriegen
was ist das
und wie sollen wir bekommen
es gibt das kann man glaube ich wirklich
sagen eine bemessung des schwarzen kinos
und zwar ich würde schon beim moonlight
ansetzen denn ich mache meinen oscar
gewonnen und so also der ist weder barry
jenkins ist wirklich mit dem smm
hollywood establishment angekommen und
hat natürlich immens viele türen
aufgestoßen für andere religion
wer war ein kugler natürliche
blockbuster bleibt ernte da passiert
ganz viel und ich muss sagen ich finde
das alles deutlich spannender als das
was mein wegen ich könnte
china macht er jetzt gerade wieder
ausgezeichnet wurde übrigens super sagt
die geschichte erzählt dass sie für die
nominierungen der golden globes gar
nicht aufgestanden ist
weil nämlich universal das studio das
diesen film vertreibt hat
pressevorführungen arrangiert screenings
für die mitglieder der vollpreis in
hobart damit die das den film sehen
können um zu erwägen ob sie ihm eine
nominierung geben was ich auf jeden fall
getan hat und zwar für die regie
betrieben sie für die beiden darsteller
hauptdarsteller auf jeden fall und
vielleicht noch für den darsteller von
onkel der eine großartige uhr laden
kleine rolle aber zu den vorführungen
ist niemals gekommen
das fand ich nun wirklich erstaunlich
was da natürlich auch dazu führte dass
der film keine nominierung bekommen hat
und also auch keine golden globes jetzt
hoffen wir mal dass es bei den oscars
ein bisschen anders aussieht werden wir
ja dann nächste woche
danke für diese reise egal wie sie
ändert